why are we all so obsessed with the
Joker
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen we are
tonight's entertainment there of course
several explanations for this for one he
is one of the oldest villains in comic
book history his first appearance dating
all the way back in 1940 with Batman
issue number one but I think what really
propelled the character to fame was in
its various incarnations throughout
history from comics to television movies
video games and animation the Joker is
probably one of the most readapted
villains in history and understandably
the question of who did it best is an
ongoing debate but I think it's an
unfair question considering that every
incarnation of the character more
specifically the four different types of
Joker we've seen throughout history are
all entirely different characters but
without even just one of them the Joker
would not have evolved into the perfect
villain we know today
Joker's initial appearance in comics was
very different from the Joker we know
today his appearance in Batman number
one portrayed him as a smart and capable
criminal driven primarily by greed
committing a series of murders to steal
precious jewels perhaps the most vital
treat that was first established was his
penchant for theatricality announcing
his crime via radio before they even
happened this would in time become a
trope that would be used again
and again every day he doesn't people
will die
she was smart cunning in ruthless but
despite at all the Joker was still just
another criminal I'll be it with an
unusual sense of humor several critics
have viewed this Joker as a perfect
example of the trickster archetype one
of the many archetypes devised by
psychoanalyst Carl Jung in literature
these are characters who show high
levels of intelligence use their mind to
play tricks or disobey any established
rules another great example of this
archetype is Loki from the Norse
mythology and subsequently the Marvel
Comics who like the Joker treads a thin
line between malicious violence and
harmless humour when the Silver Age of
comics hit in the 50s DC began toning
down the evil side of Joker to market
their books for children and to avoid
strict censorship the 1942 story The
Joker walks the last mile became a
turning point that transformed the
unusual menacing serie killer into a
joke and Cesar Romero's portrayal of the
character in the 1960s television series
Batman only solidified this image
depicting the character as an
intelligent and mostly harmless
prankster with an unusual set of gadgets
as the show's popularity waned so did
the Joker until in 1973 the character
made a return in an almost
unrecognizable four
[Music]
under writer Dennis O'Neil the Batman
comics began taking a darker and
grittier turn with it
the villains Batman number 251 signified
the return of the Joker as a criminal
and a serial killer it was at this time
that Joker truly turned mad oniel and
the writers who came after him began
focusing on Joker's insanity and with it
came the creation of the landmark Arkham
Asylum Joker was no longer scary because
he was a ruthless criminal but because
he was an insane and unpredictable one
writer Steve englehart's Ark the
laughing fish was an iconic story that
exemplified this insanity showing the
Joker poisoning the water supply to make
the fish look like him so he could
copyright and profit off of them the
same story was also adapted in the 90s
Batman the Animated Series expertly
voiced by Mark Hamill whose Joker was
heavily inspired by the Joker of the 70s
it's a ridiculous premise but
nonetheless the portrayal of the Joker
is absolutely terrifying the era
signified a huge shift in the
characterization of the Joker but the
transformation was far from complete all
of this changed with just one work that
would revolutionize the idea of the
Joker for years to part Alan Moore's The
Killing Joke
[Laughter]
published during the Dark Age of comics
when stories became even darker and more
mature to target adult audiences The
Killing Joke was a revolutionary work
for the character for a number of
reasons first it established the idea
that the Joker has no specific origin
contrary to popular belief The Killing
Joke does not tell a definitive origin
story for the Joker but only a possible
inspired by a story that was already
told years ago in Detective Comics
number 168 what is definitive his
Joker's view on his past this turned the
Joker from an evil man to an idea an
embodiment of his belief and with it the
Joker became more vocal about what he
believes in such as his frightening
observation that all it takes for
someone to become like him is just one
that's how far the world is from where I
am just one bad
the second revolutionary aspect was in
the novel's interpretation of Joker's
relationship with Batman Moore saw
Batman and Joker as a mirror image of
each other both creations of a random
and tragic event that led to an
alternate identity and opposing views of
the world
this meant that their fights were no
longer just physical but really a
philosophical The Killing Joke opened
the floodgate to other stories that
began exploring the Joker as a
philosopher it was also what heavily
inspired Jack Nicholson's iconic
portrayal of the character in Tim
Burton's Batman as you can see his Joker
was really a combination of all the
Joker's before him the kam penis of the
sixties the insanity of the 70s and the
philosophical implication of the modern
era this is perhaps why Nicholson's
portrayal was so iconic as it provided
the most comprehensive look at the
character that has drastically evolved
over the years until 2008 when director
Christopher Nolan and Heath Ledger
proved that Joker's transformation was
far from over
Ledger's portrayal of the Joker was
quite unlike anything we've seen
there were characteristics that clearly
made him the Joker like his pension for
theatricality the multiple origin
stories and I'm a cop sense of humor but
if Nicholson's Joker was more of a
performance artist Ledger's was that of
a terrorist who exploded the modern fear
of political and philosophical extremism
in the post 9/11 America he was an
anarchist who not only refused to follow
the established order but actively
sought to destroy it introducing chaos
to the political landscape of Gotham as
it's an agent of chaos
Nolan also provided a specific
philosophy to ground the character
nihilism a philosophical belief that
denies all meaningful values in life
one-credit compared the Joker - what
Friedrich Nietzsche ironically called
uber mich or Superman a beam that
independently decides on what's right or
wrong and asserts their own belief into
the world
others also notice that this
interpretation of the Batman and the
Joker's relationship mirrored the
Nietzschean philosophy of the master and
slave morality Joker being the master
morality that creates and defines its
own rules without the approval of others
and considers what benefits them to be
good while Batman serving as the slave
morality that is bound by existing laws
and distinguishes right from wrong the
two in constant battle for what each
finds just Ledger's Joker was scary
because like The Killing Joke and
embodied an idea of chaos and Anarchy
that couldn't be bullied reasoned or
negotiated with an entity that Batman
can't just win physically Joker's
transformation is an ongoing one the
most recent adaptation by Joaquin
Phoenix seems to be more political
representing him as a Marxist figure and
in recent comics Scott Snyder portrayed
the Joker as an almost demonic figure an
evil as old as a city of Gotham itself
and perhaps this is why we're all so
obsessed with the Joker it's a character
that constantly changes and evolves to
reflect our various fears to borrow the
mind of Nietzsche it's not the abyss
you're staring into that scares you but
the abyss staring back with a big loud
like smile
see madness as you know is like gravity
all it takes is a little push